[Musique]
c'était il ya six ans presque jour pour
jour
et pourtant je m'en souviens comme si
c'était hier 11 novembre 2013 nous
commémorions comme chaque année les
soldats tombés durant les guerres que
notre pays a traversé ces soldats morts
pour la france la nation a souhaité leur
rendre hommage
en inscrivant leur nom sur les monuments
aux morts de nos villages et de nos
villes pourtant je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de ressentir un certain
malaise lorsque je m'arrête devant un de
ces monuments et que j'ai grain
la liste des noms qui s'y trouvent
inscrits qui est cette jeune allard qui
est ce but staff barnier qui est ce
francisque jourdain avait-il 20 30 ou 40
ans à quelle bataille at il participé
dans quelles circonstances est il mort
comme la plupart d'entre nous je suis
bien incapable de le dire
et pourtant ces hommes ne sont pas
étrangers ce sont nos aïeuls notre
grand-père notre arrière grand père
votre grand oncle peut-être ce sont nos
morts mais leurs noms ne nous renvoie
plus à rien en un sens on pourrait dire
qu'ils sont morts deux fois une première
fois sur les champs de bataille et une
deuxième fois dans nos mémoires et ce
terrible constat prend évidemment une
résonance toute particulière en ce 11
novembre 2013 nous sommes alors à la
veille des commémorations du centenaire
de la première guerre mondiale et cela
apparaît tout à fait ce qui dérange
alors que nous disposons aujourd'hui des
moyens considérables faire par la
révolution numérique nos enfants nous
ont fait quasiment aucun progrès pour
retracer le destin de ces soldats morts
sur les champs de bataille j'en étais là
de mes réflexions lorsque j'apprends
presque incidemment temps l'information
et peu relayée par les médias
que le ministère de la défense vient de
lancer programme de transcription d'un
fonds d'archivés se fondent archives
je le connais bien j'ai été amené le
consulter en ligne plusieurs fois pour
retracer le parcours de mes ancêtres
il s'agit d'un immense fichiers d'un
million 400 mille fiche recensant
l'ensemble des morts pour la france de
la grande guerre
il contient une mine d'informations sur
chaque soldat sa date et sa commune de
naissance sa date et sa commune de décès
son unité d'appartenance ans tous de 14
à 17 champs d'information mais ces
informations en l'état ne sont que très
partiellement exploitables pourquoi
parce que en réalité elles ont été
écrites elles ont été rédigées à la main
et elles n'ont pas encore été transcrite
dans une base de données le ministère de
la défense avait bien envisagé de
confier ce travail à un prestataire trop
cher du coup il a décidé de le confier
au public mais le programme est lancé de
manière quelque peu confidentielle est
présenté dans des termes techniques qui
paraissent devoir le confiner à un
cercle restreint d'initiés
pourtant j'en ai immédiatement l'intimé
conviction
ce programme représente une formidable
opportunité qu'il y aurait il de plus
beau que de voir s'entend après une
nation entière se mobiliser pour rendre
hommage à ceux là même qui ont sacrifié
sa vie pour elle un hommage à travers un
acte simple concret mais extrêmement
mais très fort symboliquement la
transcription d'une fiche
mais qu'y aurait-il de plus beau que de
voir ce programme intégralement réalisée
pour la commémoration du centenaire de
l'armistice le 11 novembre 2018
mais évidemment le défi paraît colossal
1 million 400 mille fiche c'est énorme
il faudrait un homme seul 40 ans de
travail à raison de cinq minutes par
fish et sans un seul jour de repos pour
en venir à bout
je fais le calcul il y à un million
quatre cent mille fiche et 1800 jours
nous séparent alors du centenaire de
l'armistice milices
un million quatre cent mille / 1800
égale 800 800 autrement dit il suffirait
que nous soyons 800 à transcrire une
fiche par jour pendant toute la durée du
centenaire pour que la base de données
des morts pour la france de la grande
guerre soit intégralement compléter pour
leurs 11 novembre 2018 pour le
centenaire de l'armistice tout va
désormais oui le dire mais encore
faut-il réunir ses 800 personnes
cette task force de 800 internautes en
tant que professionnel du web je suis
bien conscient de la puissance des
réseaux sociaux et j'ai l'idée de la
mettre à contribution
quelques jours plus tard tout tout va
aller très vite puisque quelques jours
plus tard j'ouvre un compte dédié aux
projets sur le réseau social twitter
je m'engage publiquement à transcrire
une fiche par jour pendant toute la
durée du centenaire et à m'en faire le
relais sur les réseaux sociaux et
surtout je demande aux internautes de
faire de même le sort en est jeté je ne
peux plus faire machine arrière et me
voilà engagé dans un marathon de 1800
jours d'affilée avec le risque que
personne ne se présente pour
m'accompagner dans ce pari fou et de
fête
au bout de huit mois une trentaine de
participants seulement me rejoint dans
l'aventuré
au rythme où vont les choses la base de
données ne sera pas intégralement indexé
avant l'an de grâce 2046 c'est mal parti
mais j'ai l'idée de lancer des sortes de
mini campagne des opérations spéciales
en lien soit avec l'actualité soit avec
des événements commémoratifs qui
représentent autant de petits défis à
l'intérieur du grand défi général hélas
cela marche et même au delà de mes
espérances de nouveaux volontaires
affluent nous étions 30 et nous serons
bientôt plus de 300 est désormais le
défi 1 j1 paie un jour un poilu n'est
plus mon défi c'est le défi d'une
communauté entière soudée autour d'un
même objectif est animé par un
exceptionnel engagement je ne
connaissais pas et j'apprends à les
connaître
eric est officier de carrière
il consacre tout son temps libre à la
transcription à l'indexation
il indexe à lui seul 30 mille fiche
l'équivalent d'un an de travail sans un
seul jour de repos
marie-hélène les documentalistes dans
une administration elle aussi elle
consacre quasiment tout son temps de
loisir à l'indexation à l'index plus de
10000 fiche du département de la somme
son département viti lapointe et
québécoise grâce à elle et à l'équipe
qu'elle a su fédérer autour d'elle une
région entière
la bretagne et pour la première fois
intégralement index au printemps 2010 8
j'ai l'honneur d'indexer la dernière
fiche des poilus morts pour la france
originaires de l'hexagone
émile larmande est un jeune cultivateur
de 26 ans originaire de l'hérault
incorporé au 2e régiment du génie
lorsque le premier conflit mondial
éclate il meurt à ypres le 15 décembre
1914 le défi un jour un poilu 1 j1 paix
et finalement relevé le 30 avril 2018
à 16h46 très précisément avec six mois
d'avancé sur notre objectif c'est pour
moi et pour l'ensemble de la communauté
une immense joie et un jour inoubliable
un immense mémorial est désormais
constituée grâce au recoupement permis
par la base de données constituée
on sait désormais que le jour le plus
meurtrier de l'histoire de france de
l'histoire la grande guerre mais aussi
de l'histoire de france n'est pas comme
on l'a longtemps cru le 22 août 1914 le
jour de l'offensive des grandes
offensives allemandes mais le 25
septembre 1915 le jour de la grande
offensive franco britannique de
champagne et d'artois et combien
d'autres résultats nous attendent
les données transcrite par les
internautes sont désormais disponibles
en open source est offerte aux
investigations des chercheurs et du
grand public
au delà c'est déployés durant ces cinq
années une forme de commémoration
participative citoyenne par laquelle
chacun a pu devenir un acteur à part
entière de l'histoire et de la mémoire
acteurs de la mémoire et de l'histoire
chacun d
anticipant les deux venus en apportant
sa petite pierre à l'édifice commun
mais ces participants il est le sont
aussi sont devenus aussi acteur de la
mémoire de l'histoire en un autre sens
et ce mouvement là est un mouvement de
fond qui me paraît bien plus important
encore ils le sont devenus par le
cheminement qu'ils ont été amenés à
accomplir pour la plupart elles sont
parties de la transcription de la fiche
d'un aïeul morts pour la france
puis ils sont passés aux poilus de leur
commune puis aux poilus de leur
département de leur région ou de la même
unité que leurs aïeuls en réintégrant
ces destins par rapport à un contexte le
contexte d'une bataille et au delà le
contexte d'une guerre autrement dit
partant d'une histoire qui les
concernaient en propre personnellement à
titre familial les en sont venus à
explorer tout un pan de notre histoire
commune
cette histoire qui nous rassemble la
bonne nouvelle c'est que ce chemin qui
mène de la petite à la grande histoire
de l'histoire intime familiale à cette
histoire partagée qui nous rassemblent
autour d'un destin commun
vous pouvez à votre tour le parcourir
comment en commençant par explorer
l'histoire de votre famille d'un
grand-père d'un arrière-grand-père d'un
grand oncle pour en venir à dérouler le
fil qui les relient et qui vous relie à
travers eux aller à notre histoire
commune grâce
aux nouveaux outils dont le centenaire
numérique dont le centenaire a permis la
démultiplication
il est désormais à la portée de tout un
chacun de devenir un acteur de la
mémoire et de l'histoire pour construire
ensemble un futur mieux éclairé par les
leçons du passé
tous acteurs de l'histoire tous acteurs
de la mémoire je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]